thank you
[Music]
so when I saw this uh news article I
felt like there was a little bit of a
double standard but you tell me if you
agree I disagree already
why because I don't I don't believe in
double standards dude oh you disagree
with just me in general I just disagree
with how you use that what's the double
standard so when uh
it's uh it's usually when something is
unfair to a different party while that
same thing is fair to another
were you just listening to the sign
language expert next to you and that's
how you know I had a couple cues and I
got it from my man I think he wanted to
get some notes but I don't believe in
cheating so and I was like [ __ ] yeah I
think I remember this but yeah sorry
Ryan continue with the all right good
Dodge yeah nice work really good there's
a woman who is setting up an online
database she's making this website
that's kind of like a Trip Advisor of
sorts but I love TripAdvisor what you do
is you write a review on the last guy
you dated
[ __ ]
wait even if you're not the last guy you
dated yeah even if you're not with them
that means it's all bad reviews yeah
that's horrible that's that is terrible
how many people are actually gonna write
a bonus review if they broke up on a
terrible state or in a in a bad State
like or how many people are gonna admit
the responsibility of their part in a
Bad Religion okay pause they they can
write the review but it has to be like a
year after the fact so the emotions are
depleted and not so present in their
writing capability how are you so
emotionally aware
um this is this is tripping me out I'm
freaked out but also what about the
hypocrisy of rape my professor
oh how is this tied together because
people are very biased all the time and
they're students you know and then this
poor Professor can't get tenured because
because all these students bad students
are blaming teachers exactly and they're
not talking about their work ethic
interesting all right
how would you feel if a man set up a
site where men said what they thought
about hey okay that Nick is a double
standard
I think you're misusing it actually I
think she knows what it means but I'm
not sure I don't know wait till Brian
explains a little bit more yeah
what's that if dudes talk about their ex
chicks uh-huh can we is that allowed
I don't think it would go very well on a
website well what if it's more like what
if it's more like a less subjective and
more objective like a survey as if like
you're you know when you go to like a
store or restaurant or something so it's
not like why do you did you stop dating
this guy it's like this [ __ ] but it's
more like was he chivalrous did he cover
the bill and you have a spectrum one to
ten yeah you know what I'm saying so
it's not it's even if it didn't work out
for you there's an objectivity that
somebody might still be into what was
something that a guy did on a date with
you that was a deal breaker
and you're like ah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
that was a deal breaker not be
interesting enough oh yeah
like if I was in control of let's say 90
of the conversation so I was basically
talking to myself oh yeah so he wouldn't
like
like you would you wouldn't say anything
about himself yeah like I would drive
the conversations I would have the
questions
and he would just answer and then be
like okay but then it would just be like
it would segue into something I don't
know some sort of superficial thing but
a boring [ __ ] just boring or are you
trying to agree with you too much
um because he wants to get laid Yeah
there is right well see I let them fall
into that trap and then I'll disagree
with them to see if like oh I'll make
like a hot take because people would
disagree with yeah of course I'm for
abortion and you're like oh I think I'm
I'm actually against it he's like yeah
like I think that's [ __ ] up when they
kill babies yeah exactly and then I'm
like okay I think we're done here well
wait so how often does that happen where
like they flip-flop based on your
reaction to whatever they're saying uh
pretty often and why are you crazy yeah
pretty often but that's also that's also
attributed to if you like with Colleen I
know that if you can't detect or sarcasm
you don't [ __ ] stand it yeah you suck
you suck already yeah I don't know she's
very dry very yeah sarcastic
no
wait what are you even doing here
Anthony is already on the shopping block
bruh can I say something can I sit next
to somebody else please you can we'll
switch you can come this way
I'm not even blowing on it that's your
mouth
be careful what you wish for you're
right you're right
[Laughter]
it's such a hacky like I [ __ ] love it
wait somebody just clipped that but on
like Loop hey yeah hey there could be a
guy next to you that you're testing but
he's not even really listening to you
he's just waiting to talk
he doesn't even know you're testing
so when you oh my God
so when you take this whole thing into
account here's here's a couple points
that I kind of see and I understand
in a perfect world this would help
protect women from potential abusers oh
I see physical abuse right if you were
like hey this dude I dated socked me in
the face 24 hours a day I don't know and
it would help kind of deter other women
from falling for the same traps semi
Megan's Law I'm waiting for Steve to say
did she deserve it
did she deserve it and he was a did it
feel good I I knew I knew you know I'm
still learning here you still read the
room yeah you're new it's funny look at
him she's picking up the intention
though yeah no a lot of Street
performance it's just because today
you're not sitting on the believe all
women side I threw her off and Steve are
combined we we [ __ ] believe everybody
we need to become [ __ ] Megatron we
[ __ ] we believe so hard yeah we I
believe all my ancestors are women too
oh geez that's a lot of women so there
are a lot of accusers there
in this perfect world will that where
that works out pretty great right
because otherwise how do some women
really know like it would be helpful if
a woman was like yo check it out if he
says this and starts his game off with
this don't trust him and like because a
lot of guys do run the same [ __ ]
routine I think the good outweighs the
bad side of this okay so I think a lot
more good can come out of it obviously
there's gonna be bad where people are
just gonna be crazy and like talk mad
[ __ ] but the upside is probably more
favorable what's the what's the upside
you know someone like like what you said
about the abusive stuff okay did I say
that weird I said that word well I feel
I feel like at that point they might as
well make that the intention versus like
you wouldn't go on to a website to look
for all the reviews of somebody that
like is somebody worth your time that
everybody else [ __ ] didn't end up
going after so you might as well put the
intention there for like and call the
app like The Blacklist okay you know
what I'm saying that way you could look
up people be like this was on The
Blacklist I'm gonna avoid them you know
what what if it's like Steve doesn't
like the [ __ ] and I'm like yeah cause I
was trying to [ __ ] you for too long and
you're like that's not fair that's not a
good review
so but I think
the problem with that is if it's just
like one-off reviews you have to make
the reviews somewhat credible so there
has to be like 10 reviews of the same
person saying like the same thing so
it's like Ryan's this this and this said
by five people so I was like five dead
people
I said Steve in the first place well and
it can't be the other way around because
usually it's like a Yelp review or be
like accredited reviewer has been to
like has done like 800 reviews but on
this part if one person's done like 800
views it's like you're the problem right
all right right I think that that's
something that's directly from police
reports oh like you just pull you know
like Carfax see Bart ruins
straight from there and you got dudes
names yeah and it shows all the victims
they [ __ ] been whooping on well it's
like what's my Instagram oh cars or or
you know how like on coinbase you have
to [ __ ] take a picture ID if you want
to leave a review okay you gotta [ __ ]
take a picture hey YC review I think for
sure you have to be you should have to
be a verified real you should be a real
person because if you're gonna talk some
[ __ ] yeah you gotta stop gotta show your
face it's got to be Incredible's icon so
it better yeah it better be a [ __ ]
real thing yeah yeah got it so with that
in mind in your personal life Anthony oh
[ __ ] if this website existed what do you
think your satisfaction percentage would
be dude I'll say it 10 out of 10 dude
this guy's at 10. you think he'll be a
10 out of 10. in 100 scale like a Rotten
Tomatoes I'm I don't know what they
would Judge Me Maybe I don't think
anybody would give me a 10 out of 10.
but I will say every single one of my
former relationships whether series or
not serious ended amicably you don't
think any one of the relationships with
many of them like I'm still you know
what that means you're meh
I can't go with you but I'm not mad
I still think you're a 10.
having intense feelings means having a
take means not being men Anthony
amicably
oh dude cool bro Anthony was like yeah
like I went into the body booth and I
voted libertarian because like yeah we
didn't win but like you know man
whatever is this what you wanted Ryan
this is what you you were setting it up
for him to spike it little sentence
Spike gameplay I don't know what
volleyball even is what is this [ __ ]
betrayal hey dude
I'm gonna go [ __ ] unpredictable dude
he's charging up I'll [ __ ] talk in
the next 30 minutes somewhere charge up
for the next seven videos
on the flip side then if there was a
male website counterpart to this do you
think you would rate any of your exes a
failing grade I would if they cheated
he's looking at me he's asking me
[ __ ] stop being Joe wait
I'm Joe so I'm Joe
yeah get my Piccolo
if I'm gonna be Joe
that's a duck call or something
I was just gonna say this is uh maybe a
terrible character flaw of mine but I
find that let's say for something like
Yelp or like complaining about stuff I'm
more inspired and triggered to go on to
a public forum like that and rate a view
when something [ __ ] pissed me off
then when I just had a quality
experience who does who does a few other
things human nature yeah people love to
complain that's what I'm saying you know
what I mean it's like two yeah even if
it was like a semi-neutral platform to
like use for these things there's a
human nature thing where I'd rather
complain and use a space than like oh
things are good I'm like not gonna worry
about it right it's like with flights
nobody ever goes like Oh my God at
United that was a wonderful experience
no you only go like [ __ ] hats
like a delay and changes but I'll try to
talk to this [ __ ] about you know what I
mean like you [ __ ] go ham on those
yeah yeah yeah so I I I'm in that
[ __ ] generic regular human piece of
[ __ ] bunch that feels more compelled to
complain about something that's terrible
then like write a positive review out of
my way unless it was so extraordinary
that they totally deserve it okay do you
think but then if it was that
extraordinary you'd still be with them
instead of to write these reviews though
do you get like 10 off your next
girlfriend you should you should well so
far the concept really is that utopian
idea of protecting women from like you
know toxic man or future abusers things
like that prison a toxic man just any
guy who isn't me
yeah pretty much which is what we can do
yeah it's a little bit oh well that's
not me I would never do that to you it's
like
hello like so then it's more likely men
or women to abuse a platform like this
who do you think is more like women
using women yeah Colleen said it I'm
glad
I know I'll take it for you guys don't
worry about it I got you I'm gonna use
her as a meat shield and say that
Colleen said yes you know what's crazy I
believe that I I agree that women would
probably be more likely to take it to
another level in that direction of like
um you know taking the emotional route I
think if this was a male platform it
would be way [ __ ] worse because men
are more likely to expose revenge porn
yeah and that's what the website would
turn into if it was a man-led site I
also do think girls yeah but women also
don't get the details right so
oh like the directions I was playing and
the review of their experience so they
may exaggerate or de-exaggerate their
penis size right there yeah you guys get
it wrong you guys always underestimate
always we're bringing it
we're bringing way more than you even
think we were but you guys never give us
credit yeah
I'm busy with your eyes closed you guys
know that no that [ __ ] drives me [ __ ]
crazy yeah it was just like like the
meme about me is I have a big team as
well when women laugh at it until that's
not a big piece this is a small Bean I'm
like oh my God I can't believe this
[ __ ] they have all the power
it's [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]